Our land burned down five years ago, and what
is mainly growing back, are these mimosa trees.
Or, also known as acacia.
If nothing is done to the land,
it's likely that catches fire again.
To have a better fire break and more space,
we want to clear the area behind Basekamp.
We have to chop a bunch of mimosa trees,
but we realized we don't know much about them.
So, we are going to visit an expert,
that studied them for 20 years.
And also, try to build things with them ourselves.
Welcome to a new Project Kamp update.
So, as you can see, here is the kitchen container.
And, here is the mimosa forest, where it starts.
We already started chopping down here,
but there is a lot to go still.
So, before, we couldn't start this work,
because we were not allowed to use power tools.
Everything was super dry.
The soil is now super wet, rain started,
and we are now allowed to start full on.
It's a super dense bushy area, so it's difficult to go through.
A lot of fallen trees around...
And, if we find a native tree, we for sure keep it.
So, this is a public road, and where we'll mark
the end of our cutting section.
This is one of the edges, but we will just leave
a bit of a line of trees.
So, we're protected a bit from the view.
And this, is the other edge.
So, we opened this last year from the lake, up till Basekamp.
So, we could water the plants,
and we will stop until here.
This is the team.
It will be a bit fluctuating,
because it will be rainy.
And, people will come, and go all the time.
But, we're ready to start!
- What are you doing?
Trying to compress your wood, so it takes up less space.
We've been clearing the patch for a couple of days now.
Hard work, but still cannot see much change.
Lots of bushes and trees.
Anyway, our main reason to chop down the mimosas,
is to reduce fire risk.
Our neighbor Antonio experienced the fire in 2017,
and he has it cleared.
So, we are taking Antonio's advice.
We will clear a 10-meter security area around our Basekamp,
before we continue with the rest of the patch.
Careful! Oh my god!
- Run, run, run, run, run!
This guy you see cutting mimosas hasn't been
properly introduced yet.
He's the youngest in our group, full of energy, and fun!
Hey! I'm Tasman, 21 years old, and freshly imported from Australia.
Just like my mate the mimosas, but not so invasive.
I've been traveling for a couple years, and come with
a strong passion for plants and native species.
I came to Kamp to expand my knowledge on construction,
and sustainable land management.
Outside of Kamp, I enjoy challenging myself,
and exploring natural spaces.
In the future, I'd like to move more into natural
resource management, but also still lots to learn.
Alright-y, enough talking! Let's get back to work.
As good as it's gonna get!
That's fun.
Where was it?
- In the brambles.
Some little mushroom...
Hello! Welcome to autumn!
At the moment, the space around the lake, is quite narrow.
It's hard to access it.
This is why we will take away these mimosas,
dead trees, and rumbles in between.
So, we create open space around the lake, to take on next steps.
We finally made our way to the lake.
We have a clear patch, from the back of the container,
up until here now.
The next step is gonna continue at the back.
In the middle of all of these mimosas, that we have been clearing out,
we found a native tree and we've drawn on it.
So, most of the place now is cleared.
We made a few different organized piles.
This is pile number one, with small burnt sticks: they will be chipped.
This is pile number two, which is burned wood as well,
but too thick to be wood chipped.
And, this is pile number three.
It's the top of the fresh mimosas,
that will also be for the wood chipper.
This pile doesn't have a number.
We don't really know what to do...
It's the pile of the brumbles, and it's not so cool if it's still on the floor,
because it just gets stuck in our clothes.
We made it into a pile.
We can't really make fires at the moment,
and we don't know what to do with it.
For now, it just lays here.
These two piles are the ends of the fresh mimosas.
Because they are fresh, it's not very easy
for the wood chipper to chip them.
And, they are also a bit too thick...
So, we've separated them into different sizes, and they will be used
for different projects as you will see.
Although mimosa is all over Portugal,
it seems that people don't make stuff with them.
The wood is not very strong, but we will do
some experiments to find some applications.
Trying different techniques like carving, weaving,
landscaping, or carpentry.
Let's start with Martijn and Emma.
So, for our mimosa project, we're gonna do some wood carving.
I am going to make a wash powder measuring spoon.
I'm gonna make a back scratcher.
For my carving, I'm going to use a hatchet, carving knife, my spoon knife...
My chisels most of the time, and a wooden hammer.
But, I saw that Frank is using it at the moment,
so I think I'm gonna make one myself real quick.
Also from mimosa trees.
Let's start!
- Let's go!
This is for my hammer...
Is your hammer ready?
What do you think?
Ah, it feels good!
A nice sharp knife.
I'm going to use my spoon carving knife now,
to make the hollow space in the spoon.
We've got all these cultural differences,
about how much washing powder should be used.
We've got this American guy,
who says you have to load the whole thing.
They always like to go big, you know?
We've got this German guy, who says it should be 98.5.
They're really precise.
So, to settle this matter, I called my mother,
and she said it should be 110.
So, we're going for that...
- Your mother?
- My mother, yeah...
- Gender roles!
I think I'm finished with the spoon.
It's got a nice scoop...
Nice interior...
I gave a little bit of sanding on the edges, to smoothen them,
but I'm gonna leave all these cutting marks.
I like the aesthetics of that.
Now that the wood carving is done, it works actually.
It's nice.
Oh, that felt good, eh?
Pound it!
Hey, Emma!
Ah! You also finished your piece.
- Yeah! You too, I see.
Wow! That's a nice back scratcher.
- Yeah, you did a nice job too, man!
Hey there!
I'm Rita, and I volunteer here at Project Kamp.
My mimosa project is a weaved basket,
made out of the bark of the mimosas.
This was our first prototype -- our first experiment with weaving.
For this one, we decided to go thinner,
so the strips are half the width.
I think the other ones were around four centimeters,
and these ones are around two centimeters, I would say.
And, we doubled the amount of strips, because of that.
We went from having 12 strips, so 6 by 6, to 24.
The main principle of weaving is: you have vertical lines of material.
And then, horizontal lines.
I'm just going to see where the last strip is.
So, if it was under, then this one has to be over,
and this one is over, so I go under.
And just repeat the process.
It's always good to have a spray bottle in hand.
So that you can mist that your working in.
Or, even the basket itself.
And, make it more flexible, so that you can shape it.
Our basket is finished,
It's been three or four days since I weaved it, and that you saw the final result.
Now, it's pretty dry.
It's not going anywhere.
I kind of like how rough it is, so I don't really mind that there is
some irregularity, and the shape isn't totally squared.
The most important thing: it's waste free,
so you are not purchasing any materials.
It's a zero kilometer material supply...
Maybe, this would be a really cool research module for you guys to join in,
and maybe give some other ideas for weaving.
Looking forward to find more uses for the mimosa bark,
because we seem to have an infinite supply of them.
Let's see what else happens in the meantime.
So now, we have this beautiful pizza table.
That we also use as a workspace, during the week.
But, it turns out that most of our chairs are too low,
and we cannot work at a comfortable position here.
So, I thought it would be nice to have a bar stool,
to be able to do that.
Number one is ready, three more to go.
I'm going to cut the top to the final height, which--
Hey guys! I'm making a video here!
The stool itself is ready now, but as you can see,
it's not very comfortable yet.
It needs a seat, and let's see if Charlie and Rita can do something about that.
Now that the stool is finished, Martijn can sit at the proper height,
with a straight back and work happily.
All right.
We're next to the community center...
Down on this slippery hill...
And, Liz and I are going to set up some steps,
from the mimosa cut near Basekamp.
So, let's see how we go!
Alright, that's the stairs...
I think that turned out pretty well.
Hopefully, we can get up the hill a bit easier now, in the rain.
It was good to use some of these mimosas from up the hill.
Give them another life...
Yeah, cool!
So, we've been spending quite a lot of time
with the mimosa trees by now.
But, we realized we actually don't know too much about them.
We started looking on the internet to get to know them better.
In some places, mimose is a symbol for International Women's Day.
It can have healing properties, and many ecologists like it,
because it grows fast.
So, it creates a lot of organic mass to build soil,
that retrains water and moist.
Seems like a useful plant.
But, most local people around here, actually seem to hate these trees.
Calling them invasive, useless, and fire risky.
We wanted to understand more about this.
So, we went to have a chat, with an expert that has been working
for over 20 years with mimosas.
To see how he feels about it.
My name is Manuel Fernandes.
I started to study acacia's more than two decades ago.
Mimosa is a common name, that we apply to a
plant that the botanists call "Acacia Dealbata".
It comes from Australia, from the southeast Australia, from Tasmania.
There, it is part of the under story of eucalyptus forests.
And, if, some day, the eucalyptus are chopped down,
or there's a forest fire, or some other disturbance, then...
The mimosas they find a window of opportunity.
And, for several decades, they become dominant,
until the eucalyptus grows again.
They proliferate a lot by seed.
They produce lots of seeds every year.
When you chop down one Acacia, it regenerates.
But also, the root system has the property of emitting new individuals.
A single stem of mimosa may grow
more than two meters, per year.
That's a lot, of course!
And, they don't have what we may call natural enemies,
as they do on their original area, in Australia and Tasmania.
Nowadays, it is not easy to use these plants,
because they their use is forbidden by law.
Only in special occasions, in special situations, we can use them.
But, I know some experiences of use for making compound,
for agricultural uses, and forestry uses.
Also, for making charcoal, it is very suitable, as fire wood.
And, of course, the bark of these plants is widely used
for the tanning industry.
Not any longer in Portugal, but in countries, like South Africa, and Brazil.
We can't say that it's more or less flammable,
than other species or other types of vegetation.
Depends on the surrounding landscape.
When did it rain for the last time?
Depends on the age of the plants.
That depends on a lot of factors.
Most of the people, they have some difficulty
in understanding, that mimosas are proliferating.
Because of the way we manage our lands.
They are more like a symptom.
They are more like a consequence than anything,
than a cause, of ecological change.
Fire is the trigger, in most of the occasions, but not only fire.
Every mobilization of the soil, triggers this species.
I think mimosas, in some occasions, they might even be
an opportunity, an ecological opportunity.
The only thing we need is to start to research.
We feel we know much more about mimosas now.
We have to deal with them, but also we can use them.
And, in the future, much more ideas will come along.
You are also welcome to join the discussion in the research module,
following the link in the description.
Where you can also find the full interview, with the expert.
But, still one thing to do to finish the job.
We called a friend to bring his wood chipper.
And, we will chip off some piles, to cover our land.
So, if you want to buy us a container now, or a tractor,
or a wood chipper, go to support.projectkamp.com.
So, if you have a tractor laying around,
you can donate it to us.
Could be a tractor that can handle this
kind of wood chipper, so we can shred this.
Get this organic matter, start to create soil, and regenerate our land.
Finally, the space is completely cleared and we
have easy access to it.
I will show it to you.
This is exactly what it looks like.
It's now very much fire resilient.
And, the neighbors are super happy, and we are much more safe.
Wood chips are really brilliant, and we spend the whole day chipping it.
But we have still loads of piles to go.
But, for now, we just give back all this organic material to the land.
There is some water lines, as this place is quite steep.
This will help to slow down, for the water to run through.
And, we'll just keep more water, on this part of the land.
This lake was aggressively open before,
so there is a lot of erosion happening.
And, the path was becoming shorter, and shorter.
Now, we can just walk kind of easily, and access some places easier.
We still have loads of piles to process,
and we have to check how we will do that.
It was hard work!
We worked a lot, but it was super fun as well.
This is how it looks like for now.
Next week's video, is going to be challenges,
so bring up your questions in the comments for us to answer.
Thanks for watching, and don't forget to subscribe!
If you like what we do, you can support us on Patreon,
and your help would be highly appreciated.